I remember like first kind of diving
into like flagrant when it was uh the
original crew yeah yeah um cash that's
the case and it was like kind of like a
weird Sports podcast but it evolved into
something else like super yeah very fast
yeah
um but for people who don't know like
what were the original like because
obviously Andrew went from like Guy Code
to brilliant idiots and then launching
flagrant
um what was kind of like the original
crew like what was the original
I guess theme of The Show for because
now it's it's only it's its own thing
it's way different than it was yeah yeah
yeah going super far back when Andrew
started brilliant idiots I said to him
out loud this is the only time I've ever
been jealous of you right and when
you're when he was doing the podcast
with Charlemagne and it wasn't like real
jealousy but like really what I was
thinking in my brain was I had nothing I
wasn't on guy could I wasn't on TV so he
had to take that opportunity
Charlemagne's amazing and huge I was
like you got to do that but in my mind I
was like if we did a podcast I think
that [ __ ] would go right so I but I
obviously go crush it brilliant it just
did great and then when Andrew started
talking about do us doing a podcast a
few years later I think he felt like he
wanted to start another thing also I was
obviously down and we had been kind of
like brainstorming and uh we did a
brilliant episode with Kaz we thought
Cavs was great so we brought him on
board and then the idea of doing sports
I love sports I could talk yeah you
always are throwing your little tidbits
in about sports that make me feel like
oh he's a real Sports yeah yeah yeah
yeah and Andrew likes sports but he also
understood something that we had talked
about which is like yo we can slowly dip
into these crazy things we say like when
we're hanging out just saying wild jokes
about whatever right but an easy entry
point is sports because sports fans tend
to not get super triggered about
anything right right they're not it's
not too political It's Just Sports so
the idea was always to evolve it into
something else and then Alex got more
and more involved and that was amazing
he was so funny and like we would
encourage him when he would chime in
we'd be like dude you're funny chime in
yeah and then Mark Andrew started
working with Mark and Mark is a
brilliant kid super funny super talented
he's a star and I didn't know him that
well and he's doing stand-up now he does
yeah he's well he started as a stand-up
I didn't know that NBA he's been doing
Santa for years and that's how him and
Andrew connected he opened for Andrew
and then uh Andrew brought him on board
he was like he's a smart kid he has like
good ideas for Merch and all this stuff
a lot of the set design of the new set
was more the set's crazy um yeah he does
so much of our YouTube stuff he's a
[ __ ] brilliant kid and so when Andrew
was like I want to start bringing mark
on the pot was like yeah I don't know
I'm super well but bring him on and then
I got to know him he's a great kid and
it just evolved into flagrant and then
when we built the new studio we wanted
to try to find a place for them as well
right on camera because they contribute
so much off camera yeah for sure it's
just evolved into this like four guy
hang it is definitely a hang yeah and I
love it because it is like the most I
mean I'll be saying the crazy [ __ ]
yeah when the podcast is on or my wife's
in the car she's always like what the
[ __ ] are you listening to
yeah what's wrong with you my wife
doesn't listen there's episodes where
I'm like hey I think you'll like this
one yeah listen to this one don't listen
to this one because you might divorce me
yeah yeah she's just like all right fine